[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute messbar
guten abend ihnen allen an diesem
karfreitag an meiner seite ist für den
sport wo die zähne hallo guten abend und
das sind die wichtigsten nachrichten
themen von heute
russland bestätigt das flaggschiff der
schwarzmeerflotte ist gesunken und kiew
ist wieder ziel russische angriffe
karfreitag in jerusalem friedvolle
prozession und heftige krawalle am
tempelberg und
jahrhundert spiel der eintracht
frankfurt schlägt den fc barcelona und
steht im halbfinale der europa league
über sieben wochen dauert dieser krieg
jetzt schon der ukrainische präsident
seelands gibt dankte in der nacht den
streitkräften und seinem volk den
größten teil des landes verteidigt zu
haben wie lange sie das noch durchhalten
weiß keiner russland kündigte weitere
angriffe an auch auf kiew schwere
verluste gibt es auf beiden seiten
volker tucek berichtet
diese manöver bilder taugen nur noch
fürs archiv denn die moskwa das
flaggschiff der russischen
schwarzmeerflotte ist gesunken der kreml
gibt es nach langem hin und her zu
bestreitet aber energisch die version
kers eine ukrainische rakete habe das
supermoderne kriegsschiff versenkt dort
sei munition explodiert beim abschleppen
sei die moskwa dann im sturm gesunken so
der kreml der verlust ist eine
niederlage für präsident putin die hier
2014 posierte er gerne auf dem
prestigeträchtigen
raketenkreuzer und seiner 500 köpfigen
besatzung
seit beginn des krieges mit der ukraine
diente die moskwa zudem als permanente
drohung dass russland vom meer aus jede
stadt treffen könne inklusive kiew
kabinettssitzung heute in der hauptstadt
das bild ist die botschaft es soll
geschlossenheit und zuversicht nach 50
tagen krieg vermitteln sie lenski hat
bereits in der nacht den mut seiner
landsleute gerühmt die vor allem in den
ersten 50 kriegstagen gezeigt hätten
dass die russische luftfahrt wenn es ist
auch trotz der zig milliarden dollar für
die verteidigungssysteme der eigenen
luftwaffe
dank auch an jene die gezeigt haben dass
russische schiffe auf den boden sinken
können
der krieg rückt näher heran an die
hauptstadt kiew getroffen wurde in der
nacht das gelände eines rüstungs
komplexes in dem raketen hergestellt
werden sollen angeblich auch solche mit
denen das kriegsschiff moskwa getroffen
wurde
einer meiner mitarbeiter lebte hier es
ist ein wunder dass er überlebt hat sie
sagen es gab drei verletzte nach
dem sinken der moskwa rechnen kiew und
seine bewohner in den nächsten tagen mit
verstärkten angriffen
weitere angriffe auf kiew sind
angekündigt dominik löschmeister ist für
uns vor ort wie erleben sie die stadt im
moment
ja die anspannung steigt wieder in
kirche waren selbst heute morgen
unterwegs und der stadt dann hat das
auch so gegen 11 uhr sirenengeheul
gegeben ist aber dann sonst noch nichts
passiert wir haben uns viel mit menschen
unterhalten die eigentlich gehofft haben
dass wieder etwas normalität nach kiew
einkehrt die ersten cafés haben wieder
aufgemacht und man konnte auch wieder
menschen auf den straßen sehen was man
der letzten tagen so nicht gesehen hat
aber viele haben jetzt angst und sorge
dass putin jetzt wieder mit
bombardements und mit raketenangriffen
auf kiew beginnt in einer stadt in einer
region wo sie ja immer noch hier in der
umgebung
massengräber finden aus trümmern leichen
entdecken insgesamt 900 so die zahl die
die polizei heute bekannt gegeben haben
in der ukraine
das heißt wenn es nun zu weiteren
angriffen kommt dann ist das ein
schwerer schlag und einer ja eine eine
neue qualität dann auch in diesem
konflikt
dankeschön dominik löschmeister live aus
kiew
die bundesregierung will die ukraine bei
der verteidigung stärker unterstützen
für militärhilfen wurden zwei milliarden
euro zusätzlich bereitgestellt der
größte teil davon sei für die ukraine
bestimmt das bestätigte eine
regierungssprecherin
allein rund 400 millionen euro schließen
offenbar in einen fonds aus dem waffen
für die ukraine gekauft werden
karfreitag in jerusalem in diesem jahr
erstmals seit beginn der pandemie wieder
mit ausländischen pilgern bei der
kreuzweg prozession
sie erleben ein land in angespannter
atmosphäre schon am frühen morgen gab es
am tempelberg zusammenstöße zwischen
palästinensern und israelischen
sicherheitskräften
zum paulus berichtet über einen
karfreitag im spannungsfeld zwischen
religion und gewalt
es ist fast wie vor der pandemie pilger
aus aller welt dürfen wieder nach israel
einreisen und hier in jerusalem haben
christen wieder gemeinsam an den
kreuzweg jesu erinnert streng beobachtet
von einem großaufgebot der polizei nach
den anschlägen der vergangenen wochen
gilt in israel weiterhin die höchste
sicherheitsstufe trotzdem wollten sich
viele dieses erlebnis nicht nehmen
lassen
also wenn was ist wir hatten jetzt keine
angst wenn er neutral also neutrale
gefühle weil auch passieren kann überall
über all das war am morgen wenige
hundert meter entfernt auf dem gelände
der al-aksa-moschee eskalierte die lage
unter tausenden muslimischen gläubigen
sollen rund 100 randalierer gewesen sein
sagen israelische behörden als antwort
darauf sei israels polizei auf das
gelände vorgerückt mehr als 150
palästinenser und drei israelische
polizisten wurden verletzt kritik kommt
von palästinenser gruppen die mit dem
vordringen auf ihr heiligtum eine rote
linie überschritten sehen israels
regierung jedoch beschwichtigt
wir arbeiten daran die dinge am
tempelberg und in ganz israel zu
beruhigen gleichzeitig sind wir
vorbereitet auf jede szene denn dieses
jahr feiern alle gleichzeitig in
jerusalem die muslime den ramadan die
juden das pessachfest und die christen
ostern der tag zeigt wie angespannt die
gesamtlage bleibt die israelische
regierung betont zwar immer wieder für
hysterie sei kein platz aber die sorge
dass die sicherheitslage weiter
eskaliert und weitere anschläge folgen
ist nach wie vor sehr groß heute blieb
es den rest des tages friedlich bei der
prozession genau wie beim mittagsgebet
in der moschee
jetzt zu corona da singt hierzulande die
sieben tage incidents weiter auf aktuell
1001 dennoch mahnt das
robert-koch-institut an den
osterfeiertagen zur vorsicht und
verantwortungsvollem verhalten
weil das virus vor allem alte und kranke
menschen gefährdet gilt im
gesundheitswesen ja seit einem monat die
umstrittene impfpflicht dafür mussten
erstmal die ungeimpften gemeldet werden
in einem kleineren bundesland wie
sachsen anhalt sind das zum beispiel
rund
8600 in bayern mehr als 30.000
konsequenzen drohen in bislang offenbar
nicht zeigt sibylle bassler die münchen
klinik von den 7000 mitarbeitern waren
zehn prozent vor der impfpflicht nicht
geimpft diese mussten laut gesetz
gemeldet werden es war viel auf und wir
haben die zahlen ans gesundheitsamt
zum sechzehnten abgemeldet und seitdem
auch mal etwas passiert konsequenzen für
ungeimpfte bisher keine nur wenige haben
gekündigt in bayern sind rund fünf
prozent im gesundheitswesen ungeimpft
dass die allgemeine impfpflicht vom
tisch ist sorgt für unverständnis in der
branche der schutz vor der pandemie darf
nicht alleine auf dem rücken der
beschäftigten in den krankenhäusern und
gesundheitsbereichen ausgetragen werden
wir brauchen unbedingt auch den
eigenschutz jedes einzelnen impfen ist
lebenswichtig davon sind die meisten in
den einrichtungen überzeugt auch hier im
st franziskus heim wo fast alle
mitarbeitenden geimpft sind was
allerdings ärgere seien die
angekündigten sanktionen
ich glaube dass es einfach dann auch
unangemessen ist dass dann diese leute
bedienung verbot bekommen oder auch dann
strafe zahlen müssten eine kritik die
auch vom bayerischen gesundheitsminister
ernst genommen wird die einrichtungs
bezogenen fliegt muss noch einmal auf
den prüfstand wenn die allgemeine nicht
kommt weil ich das tatsächlich als
unfair finden würde das die die an
vorderster front in der pandemie
gekämpft haben jetzt einfach für etwas
erhalten müssen wir was nichts dafür
können rasches handeln ist gefragt schon
jetzt ist das vertrauen der pflegekräfte
durch die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht empfindlich gestört
es führt zu einer missstimmung bei den
mitarbeitenden die sich da auch gedrängt
fühlen und teilweise auch schon
gekündigt haben noch sind es nur wenige
doch jede kündigung in diesem bereich
ist eine zu viel
vor genau drei jahren genau um diese
zeit stand in paris noch damm in flammen
wenig später versprach präsident makro
bis 2024 ist sie wieder aufgebaut
tatsächlich ist die weltberühmte
kathedrale nicht mehr einsturzgefährdet
die sicherungen sind abgeschlossen der
mittelalterliche dachstuhl soll in
ähnlicher form wieder entstehen ebenso
der abgebrannte vierungsturm aus holz
wie notre dame aktuell aussieht zeigt
christel haas
der helm ist pflicht inmitten der
gerüste auch für die geistlichen die
heute ausnahmsweise kurz in die
kathedrale dürfen notre dame ist immer
noch geschlossen der gottesdienst findet
deshalb draußen statt sie soll genauso
wie früher werden es ist ja auch eine
würdigung derer die sie gebaut haben
sie ist teil unserer tradition
im innern von notre dame ist eine zweite
kathedrale entstanden aus stahl die
bögen sind abgestützt das dach gewölbe
geschützt mit einer großen plane die
eigentlichen restaurierungsarbeiten
sollen bald beginnen
diesen tag werden die franzosen wohl nie
vergessen rotterdam brennt lichterloh
der spitz turm fällt in die tiefe das
gesamte gebäude droht zusammenzustürzen
die kathedrale hält stand ist aber
schwer beschädigt die brandursache ist
immer noch ungeklärt
marie-christin blöd fest ist architektin
sie überprüft jeden stein und
entscheidet welche ausgetauscht werden
muss das ist ein gutes beispiel das
zeigt was die hitze mit den steinen
macht rosetten balustraden gewölbe
wasserspeier
2500 tonnen kalkstein werden für die
restaurierung gebraucht in diesem
steinbruch werden jetzt große quader
geschnitten die später dann in kleinen
stücken ihren platz in der notre dame
ein und dann gab es heute noch einen
gast den zutritt zur kathedralen
baustelle gewährt wurde präsident makro
die sich eingehend über die arbeiten
informieren
2024 soll notre dame wieder für besucher
öffnen ganz fertig ist sie dann aber
wohl noch nicht
am langen osterwochenende zieht es viele
in den urlaub oder zu verwandten das war
heute auf den autobahnen deutlich zu
spüren im norden war vor allem die a1
betroffen wo es oft nur langsam
voranging und noch mehr geduld brauchten
die reisenden am gotthardtunnel in der
schweiz mehr als 20 kilometer stau und
wartezeiten von über 3 stunden und
jetzt fußball noch mehr audi eintrag
fans sind immer noch ganz benommen vor
glück nämlich an im regelrechten
freudentaumel das europäische fußball
märchen der frankfurter eintracht geht
weiter nach dem sensationellen 3 2 sieg
beim großen fc barcelona stehen die
hessen im halbfinale der europa league
die mitgereisten fans der eintracht
erlebten einen denkwürdigen fußballabend
im legendären kam nur
es ist ein heimspiel in der fremde für
die eintracht 30.000 statt der offiziell
nur 5000 tickets für einen gastverein
hatten sie ihre fans ergattert aussicht
barcelonas ein planungsfehler famos
unterstützt von den rängen liegt
frankfurt früh los foulefmeter kostet 1
0 führte minute
weitschuss tor 36 minute 20 der
pausenstand
noch einmal kostet platziert zum 13 0 67
minute
der berühmte fc barcelona wehrt sich
erst spät doch zwei tore in der
nachspielzeit reichen nicht fast schon
eine unglaubliche geschichte die wir
jetzt hier schreiben und die wir aber
auch weiter schreiben wollen sie wissen
nicht ob sie träumen sollen ob sich
dieser magische nacht wiederholen lässt
gerade deshalb gilt es jeden moment zu
genießen die reise nach barcelona war
alles andere als eine bauchlandung
und dank doppel torschütze christopher
im kongo zieht auch rb leipzig ins
halbfinale der europa league ein nach
einem perfekt vorgetragenen konter
erzielt der 24 jährige mittelfeldspieler
in der 18 minute bei atalanta bergamo
den führungstreffer drei minuten vor
schluss machte mit dem 2 0 per
foulelfmeter alles klar
so die deutschen tennis frauen haben
beim billie jean king cup ihre
auftakteinzel in kasachstan verloren
laura siegemund war beim 0 6 und 1 zu 6
gegen die kasachische spitzenspielerin
elena weber china chancenlos zuvor hatte
angelique kerber ihr match gegen julia
putin zwar nach drei sätzen ebenfalls
verloren jetzt müssen drei siege her
sonst droht die abstiegsrunde
ja eine jubelt die andere nicht das
war's dankeschön für morgen vielleicht
ein paar kisten mammons loch ich bringe
selbst noch heute mit zum schluss noch
was fürs auge die japanische kirsche
blüht glücklicherweise nicht nur in
japan sondern auch bei uns rosafarbenes
blütenmeer zum beispiel in mainz die
kirschblüte gilt als symbol für
schönheit aufbruch und vergänglichkeit
denn in wenigen tagen ist das schauspiel
schon wieder vorbei wer es noch sehen
oder 111 machen möchte muss sich beeilen
der ostersamstag wird fast überall schön
in der südhälfte anfangs noch starke
bewirkt und am alpenrand vereinzelt
schauer sonst aber viel sonne 8 bis 18
grad
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute-journal wir sagen
tschüss und wünschen ihnen ein richtig
schönes osterwochenende hier erwartet
sie jetzt eine reise in die serengeti
mit kleinen löwen und leoparden kinder
der savanne heißt die erste einer
dreiteiligen terra expo ist morgen wenn
sie mögen
[Musik]